well
the police are looking for the person responsible for the
death of a woman who was found
near wiggins and smoke friends streets how are
you greeted by cristian
cásseres just before 11 o'clock on
Thursday the victim was found dead
inside an apartment officials
say her ex  boyfriend was seen leaving
the house and they are considering him as
a suspect at this time this case is
still under investigation
detectives are also investigating
another fatal shooting in another apartment
fences off road and world of fire
investigators say a man was
playing with a gun when  this one was
shot one person died so
far the police have not determined if
there will be charges and for the second day in a
row the high school yesterday
was closed Thursday as a
security measure after a fight on
campus an adult and a teenager
were arrested while
eight other youths received tickets
this incident comes after reports of a
weapon in  the campus on wednesday
officers searched the school but did not
find the weapon
and violence in schools was the subject
of discussion during the clark county
school district board meeting
on thursday night
this after an increase and
violent incidents in  possible solutions were discussed on campus such
as
increasing police presence as
well as expanding current services and
programs and making changes
to student discipline guidelines
$400,000 funds were
approved to allow police as
well as social workers
to organize  visits to homes
of high-risk students and we close the
week with a sunny day but with cold
temperatures here we present the
forecast for the next eight days and
how we can see those digits because
they will rise slowly until they hit
80 degrees remember to turn back your clock
that this Sunday since the time changes
this weekend s  oy cristian cásseres
with his brief informative of iris neil
spanish was the day